So, I think it's extremely important for law firm owners and lawyers to also hold themselves
accountable.
After listening to this episode, if you go look for things in your system and you find
them, ask yourself, have I provided the training necessary?
Ensure that the team knows how to use the system.
I would say 90% of the law firms that come to us do not know how to use the system.
It's wild.
Welcome to the Tip the Scales podcast, where we discuss running and growing your law firm.
I'm your host, Maria Monroy, president and co-founder of LawRank.
Today I am joined by Yani Smith, and we talk about one of my biggest annoyances, intake.
From setting up a phone tree to gathering data to utilizing Lead Docket to empathy,
friendliness.
I literally asked her, I think, every single question I could possibly think of.
This is one of our longer episodes, but it's full with so much, so much knowledge.
I'm so grateful that she took the time to do this.
I hope that you guys find this episode valuable.
It's Smith, right?
Yeah.
The last name?
Seriously?
Yes, seriously.
To me, you're Yani.
Like, I don't think of your last name.
Okay.
You know, my name is Yanishka.
No, I didn't know that.
Yeah.
Okay.
We can save it for the podcast if you want.
We can.
All right.
Yani Smith.
Hi, Maria.
Hi.
Tell us what your business is called.
I'm Yani Smith.
Legal Intake Pros, and we help law firms remove the friction and maximize intake to grow.
So we fix the core intake issues.
It's my biggest annoyance, isn't it?
I know.
I fucking hate it.
I just wish everybody could just get it down perfect.
Ugh.
But it's hard.
It's such a tough spot for an agency, too, because it always feels like you're placing
blame on the client.
So the client's like, no, the issue's you.
And I'm like, no.
I know.
Look at your call volume.
The issue's not me.
Yeah.
But it's always a fine line of not trying to shift the blame, but also bring attention
to, well, let's talk about your intake, right?
Yeah.
Now, as much as it annoys me, I am by no means an expert.
I know that you are an expert.
So I wanted to pick your brain on what are the most important things to get down in terms
of intake?
If a firm said, hey, Yoni, I maybe don't have the funds to hire you, or we're just so far
behind that, I just want to understand the top seven things that a firm can do.
Yeah.
The first thing I want to say is I used to be that client that was calling the SEO company.
We need more leads.
We need better leads.
So I'm sorry, because I know that you guys deal with a lot.
You don't know what you don't know in a lot of ways.
And I think that what is harder to say than do is to fix these issues when you're inside
of the firm.
So that said, it takes time, and there's no easy lift, but a couple of things that you
can do.
I know that most of your clients are probably on some sort of a call tracking system.
Yes.
All real, typically.
So what we find is that a lot of clients have a call tracking system, and maybe they have
an intake software like Lead Docket.
I love Lead Docket.
Me too.
Yes, I know you do.
Lead Docket is great, but most people don't leverage all of the features, all of the capabilities
of Lead Docket, such as integrating their call tracking system with Lead Docket, adding all
of your contact sources so that if you enter the phone number in of a potential client
or you have a web form that comes in, you integrate that with the system, and it will
auto-populate and attribute to the contact source.
I have a question, though.
So we ran into this issue with attribution where they'll sign a case, they have a phone
number, but the phone number doesn't match the CallRail number.
The caller ID?
Yeah.
So it's like maybe they called from an office or their sister cell phone or something like
that where the actual phone number that is tracked in CallRail isn't the best primary
contact number.
So when we're trying to find where a case originated, is there like a secondary?
I know the answer, but I want you to explain this to people so you can put us.
Yes.
So I love this question because we do this often for our clients that might want to get
super granular about specific landing pages or location pages on their site without building
out several types of forms on their site.
So you can just use the UTM codes and enter that into Lead Docket.
You can use the UTM codes or add specific domain URLs if you're using a system like
Lead Docket.
No, no, no.
What I mean is I don't mean the call tracking number that they dialed.
I mean the number that they called from.
So the number that CallRail is tracking, say it's 800-555-5555, is not the phone number
that is the primary contact's phone number.
So at some point during intake, the callback number is a different phone number.
So it's hard to trace that this phone number from CallRail is actually attached to this
different phone number that we've attached in our CRM tool, or sorry, in our case management
software to the client.
So the client's phone number is not 800-555, it's, you know, 323-8-whatever.
Do you see what I'm saying?
Kind of.
But are they entering a different number from the device that they're on?
Yes.
You can still use the UTM codes.
How?
But I'm not saying they're entering it into the contact submission form.
I mean the intake specialist.
So in Lead Docket, this is why I love Lead Docket.
Okay.
So there is like an extra cool thing.
Yes.
Okay.
Explain this to me.
So in Lead Docket, you can get super granular.
So the way that we set up Lead Docket at Legal Intake Pros is we pull everything from the
referral URL.
So you have like the current URL, the referral URL.
If we have UTM codes that we can feed into the system as well, we will do that.
A call tracking system as well.
So when an opportunity comes in, it will actually show a trail of this is a number
they called from.
This is a digital footprint in terms of maybe the page that they're on, any UTM codes that
matched up.
So there is a way to foolproof it in a way where you'll have multiple data points in
the system.
Including their actual phone number.
Got it.
Exactly.
So there's a way to do that, but you have to – we rely on our clients to get that
information from them, especially like social media.
So if they have a social media campaign and those callers or those prospects maybe didn't
click the actual call to action on their social media to call, we'll just get the UTM codes
from them so that it will automatically attribute towards the social media campaign or whatever
other campaign that they have.
So there's ways of doing what we call foolproof tracking without necessarily needing the actual
call, right, in order to attribute to that contact source.
And are you also tracking like – so CallRail will give me like source one, like the channel
drill down.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
Kind of.
And it'll tell you like, it came from this website, but then they went to this.
Yes.
Like it actually gives you like a whole kind of history of what happened.
Are you looking at all of that?
We are looking at that.
And you can pull that information in.
So if anyone is listening and has Lead Docket, if you go to the Manage section on Lead Docket
and you go to integrations and you click on autosource roles, you'll be able to find
that.
You're welcome.
Yes.
Thank you.
Okay.
So that covers one thing.
Yes.
Okay.
What else do you recommend that law firms do like, kind of like the basics, right?
Basic.
Of intake.
I think that something that would be an easy lift that would make a really big difference
is for firms to take the time to develop a call path.
So not a script, we're pretty anti-scripts, we'll provide scripts, but the goal is to
get off the script as soon as possible.
What we mean by call path is like key points, right?
Of the things that the intake team will hit on if they're on the call with a prospect.
That way it's consistent every time.
We listen to calls all the time where you'll have a rockstar intake specialist will score
the highest score on a call and then on the next one forget to explain the contingency
fee.
It happens.
Of course.
People get distracted.
Things come up in their lives and their performance will fluctuate, they're human.
That's the biggest thing.
The biggest thing is like a firm will be like, but I have this intake specialist, she's amazing.
And I'm like, yeah, but they're still human.
And if they also know that there's no one watching, monitoring, right, quality control,
if they're having a bad day because they got in a fight with their husband or boyfriend
or something happened, right, they're human.
And they could have off days, off weeks, off months.
And when do you want to catch it?
Do you want to catch it on day one, day seven, or day 200?
What we find is that if you have a quality control system in place, so what does quality
control mean is an actual protocol that it's on schedule, that's never missed where we
listen to calls, score them, provide feedback in real time.
We're looking at the cases that we didn't sign up,
exactly why we didn't sign them up, right?
We're looking for these opportunities
and we're finding them within 48 hours, right?
Versus day 200.
But your biggest rock stars are going to make mistakes.
Mistakes are okay.
Sometimes they may not even realize
that they are regressing
or maybe missing some best practices
because if you are a high volume firm,
you're getting, some intake specialists
are going to be processing 30 calls, 35, 40 calls a day.
So forgetting to go through the contingency fee
if you're just kind of going off of your experience
and just knowing the process
is actually pretty understandable.
But if you have a call path that's,
this is a system, this is a checklist,
it's right in front of you,
it becomes just secondhand,
what is it called?
Like secondhand nature, right?
They just know that this is that process
versus one particular intake team member
might have some pre-lit experience.
So she kind of just knows to ask these questions.
It's best to have everyone follow
that same process every single time
to ensure that we're providing every single potential client
with the same type of service,
providing them with the same type of guidance.
One thing that we also see and hear a lot
is something that should be included in this call path
where they were intake specialists
will sometimes forget to just explain the process.
They'll just forget the part.
I know, it's very common, Maria.
It's very common.
I have a question
and I guess we should kind of recap it, right?
So number one is like having a source to attribute things,
like we have a Lead Docket.
Number two is having a process for-
A call path.
So I have a question,
so if we can kind of like take five.
There's one thing that I've never been able to understand
if a firm says to me,
and this happens all the time,
when we want a case, we sign it.
Like this is something that firms say to me
very confidently every single time, right?
Like when we want a case, we sign it.
We have, you know, we always sign it.
I know every case that we don't sign,
but if there's no quality control, right?
And we're looking at qualified leads or wanted cases,
different firms call it different things.
Is there like a particular term you like to use?
I like wanted cases.
Wanted cases, okay.
So if somebody says,
hey, this month we had 20 wanted cases,
and we're just taking that at face value
and not looking at,
well, what happened with the other 70 calls that came in?
How do we know that they just chose
because they couldn't close it,
they couldn't get the case signed up
to mark it as a non-wanted case?
Does this happen or am I crazy?
It happens.
It does happen.
It happens and it's tough.
So one thing I will say is that the practice of,
first, we're only gonna enter, you know,
the leads that we want into the system is just,
it will cost a firm cases
because you'll have the, you know,
that practice of maybe the receptionist will take a call
or an intake team member or maybe a lawyer.
And it's for a case that's outside of their practice area.
So they won't enter it into the system.
And it could have been an LSA call, right?
So one, we don't have the data from that call,
but then you have this practice throughout the firm
where we're not entering all leads into the system.
And eventually, how can you guarantee, like you say,
that we're actually missing the opportunity
to enter the cases that we do want?
So we do audits and we have had experiences
where we call in with a case that meets every single thing
that the firm said they wanted.
And we were told we're gonna receive an agreement
and we never receive it.
But that's what happens when you do not put a lead
in the funnel of a system to push it forward,
to remind you, to prompt you, right, to move it forward.
So-
That's heartbreaking.
It's heartbreaking and it happens.
So rule number, I don't know which one we're on, five,
enter every lead in the system, no matter what, regardless.
One, you'll be able to measure the performance
of your marketing campaigns.
Don't you at least wanna know if you're getting a lot
of bad leads from a specific campaign?
Yes.
Enter it into the system.
Every single one of them,
you're gonna learn a lot if you do that.
And as it relates to wanted cases
and being able to track, right, if they're measuring
or if they're using maybe the right statuses,
if it's marked as wanted or unwanted,
this is what you should do.
If your system allows you to parse out
what's called like a sub-status or like a sub-phase,
do that and remove the general decline.
What that means is, is that your firm,
if someone declines something or rejects it,
it has to specify that it was rejected
for gap of treatment, rejected for minor injuries,
but just the general decline that doesn't explain
why it was rejected should be completely removed.
That way, they're forced to select one of those options,
right, if a case is rejected.
What happens is, often, is that if a case is rejected,
but it was actually lost because maybe they called twice
and couldn't get ahold of them,
it's moved into rejected, declined.
When you eliminate that and then you're auditing,
let's look at the rejected minor injuries specifically,
and you're realizing that the case facts
actually include injuries,
but maybe we didn't pursue them as often
as we should have and we lost it,
we're able to then pinpoint.
So I hope that makes sense.
So I'm stating that if you have a sort of like label
or category in your intake system
that is to exclude what a wanted case is,
so rejected, for instance,
add subcategories at sub-phases,
however your system is set up,
to include the reasons why a case would be rejected
from your firm, but remove a catch-all
just declined rejected phase,
because that's usually where all of the actual wanted cases
that were labeled as rejected will live.
But even with categories, in theory,
somebody could mark a case rejected,
but maybe, so here's my fear, right?
You have a firm that is putting a lot of pressure
on the intake team.
You need to sign X amount of cases per month, right?
And they can't close a case,
and they're getting a lot of heat
for not closing those cases,
for not getting those cases signed up.
So they mark it as rejected, no injuries or whatever,
no policy, no insurance, whatever the reason is, right?
And my whole thing is like, if nobody's checking,
how do you know that it's not happening?
And maybe I'm just like inherently a distrusting person.
Like anytime, for example,
we use a CRM until we use HubSpot, right?
And if somebody marks a deal lost, I get notified
every time somebody marks a deal lost.
And there's a reason.
And I can go and watch the calls
and look at the communications and say,
well, what happened here?
Did we drop the ball?
Or was it just not a good fit?
Whatever the reason is, right?
Or they went with another agency,
which obviously it happens, right?
But for me, I'm always like,
how do I know that this was handled correctly?
And for us, like, and I assume you can do this
with Lead Docket, but everything just feeds into HubSpot.
Like it doesn't have to be manually entered.
Everything is already in there,
and it can't disappear without me being notified.
It can't be deleted, period.
They don't even have an ability to delete,
but it can't be closed unless I'm notified.
So I just don't understand why law firms don't have,
and I'm not saying that all law firms,
but some law firms don't have the same type of-
Quality control.
Yeah, and just like I, as a business owner,
forget law or agency world, as a business owner,
I want to understand what's happening
with these potential clients, right?
Like, what was their experience like?
What happened?
And there's quality control.
I will literally watch calls that my reps do,
and if something didn't go as I would have hoped,
I email the firm, and I'm like, hey, you did this call.
I watched it for quality and training purposes,
and this was sent to you, but it's actually this,
or whatever.
Like I have now the ability to address it, right?
So if a case isn't closed,
and let's say you have an intake manager,
and they listen to the calls like almost in real time,
like same day, and they catch something,
they could literally call that person back
and be like, hey, I want to connect you with a lawyer.
We have tons of experience in this, this, this, and this.
Connect it to the lawyer.
Boom, lawyer closes it.
Yeah.
Am I crazy?
No, absolutely not.
So I think that our, so I'm not gonna say all law firms.
I know that there are firms
that are listening to their calls.
Yes, no, there are.
Yeah, they're listening to their calls,
and I think that the key is to address that in real time.
So if you're listening to calls,
what are you doing with that information?
Are you, do you have a way to measure that?
So is it a scorecard?
If it is a scorecard,
are you tracking the areas that need improvement?
And how are we translating that to the team?
How are we coaching the team on some of these areas
that need to, you know, that need attention?
That specific example, though,
about miscategorizing leads is,
I don't know if there's a lot of room for forgiveness,
you know, in a firm,
or if that's happening continuously,
because it's dishonest.
It is.
But it happens.
It does.
And I can't say that I can use that as an example to coach,
because if it happens once,
do you know how to use the system?
If it happens twice,
it's, there's not a lot of tolerance for that.
And that's my whole point.
Like, if you have a system in place to
monitor this, then that was going to be my next question, right?
Like, how much tolerance would you have?
Because like, I would maybe, it would depend on how egregious it was.
Like, if it was like, okay, maybe there is like a coaching opportunity and there
was, they didn't have the knowledge to, you know, determine that this was in
fact an injury, you know, maybe there could be a hidden TBI, whatever, right?
Like something super complex, fine.
But if it's like blatantly, I couldn't close this and I marked it as
rejected, no injury, I would fire them.
Like straight up.
Like, that's just me.
I like have very little tolerance.
Assuming they know how to use the system.
Assuming they know everything.
Of course.
Like if they just, I would want to understand like what happened here.
Right.
And also like, I guess it depends on like the history of the employee.
Like they could be like, I don't know what happened.
Like I didn't mean to do that.
Like I really, I knew that this wasn't closed.
I, something happened.
It came in and I mistake it for another case.
And if you trust the rep enough or the intake specialist enough, okay, fine.
Maybe that one you forget.
But then if it happens, like you said, again, now there's a pattern here and
it's like, then I would be very like, no, this is just not a good fit.
But if you don't have this in place, if you just don't have it in place, you're
just, you're getting, you're reporting numbers back to your agency or your
marketing person that you don't know are accurate.
What I want to be careful about here is because I see it all of the time, what
you're saying is that if they know better and they know how to do better, then I'm
going to hold them accountable to that.
Yes.
So I think it's extremely important to, for law firm owners and lawyers to also
hold themselves accountable so that if, after listening to this episode, if you
go look for things in your system and you find them, ask yourself, have I provided
the training necessary?
Ensure that the team knows how to use the system.
I would say 90% of the law firms that come to us do not, do not know how to use
the system the way that it's, it's wild.
So we use something, I don't know if like law firms do this.
We used to use Traneo.
Now we switched to Guru and you can literally have these digital, like very
corporate, right?
Like I work for AT&T and every quarter it's like, you got to watch these videos
and take this quiz at the end.
And like, you hate life for that two hours, but that's just the reality, right?
But in this situation, they could have so many things digitally that they, and I'm
not saying that this replaces the human coaching and interaction because it
absolutely doesn't, but it gives you a really great starting point for a new
person comes in, you start here.
Before we even get to the role plays and the, the coaching and the actually, let
me listen to you on a call, start here, right?
Do you recommend that they have some sort of like training in place already?
We typically will start with the fundamentals when we have a, like a new
intake team member that joins a team for one of our clients, but we assess them
first.
Not everyone needs the same level of training.
Sometimes an intake specialist will have like pre-lit experience, so we can skip
the whole part about criteria and case types.
Maybe someone's completely green to the legal industry and they need like a 101.
We start with data entry best practices so that.
Wow.
So before even training them on anything else, it starts with the data entry.
The expectation of how we keep integral data, that every single lead must be
entered into the system.
And that is rule number one.
I love this.
Can you repeat that sentence one more time?
I don't remember the sentence.
You said something about intake.
Okay.
Well, we're going to like replay it.
We're going to edit this and like replay it like 10 times over and over.
Every single lead must be entered into the system.
And that is rule number one.
That's what I said.
And that's where we start.
So we start with what is intake?
Aside from legal, what is intake?
What is the purpose of intake?
What is a CRM?
How do we want to enter this information into the CRM?
What is a marketing source?
What is a contact source?
So that they're fully able to understand the importance of the information that
we're gathering and what it means to them and why the firm is collecting this
information.
So we start there and we do share some just very basic videos, but we do that
just before our one-on-one assessments.
That's how we handle it personally.
Okay.
All of our training is tailored to the intake team member.
So we do our trainings live through Zoom video and it's super tailored to how
they've assessed their experience and how they performed on the audit.
Cause we were studying them for about a month before we work with them.
Right.
Cause you guys first do an audit and we'll talk about your, your services in a
little, but just so people have context, like Yani and her team first do an
audit.
And then if you move forward with them, then you're doing the actual coaching and
data and all this crazy stuff.
So, and like in our experience, we, we, we have a really strong assessment of the
areas that they need coaching because of that.
But what if you're a law firm that like, isn't going to hire you for whatever
reason, right?
Like, should they start with data entry, like teaching their team, this is how
you use whatever case management software.
And then I guess on that, I have so many questions we could do like 10 episodes
on this, but what if they don't have Lead Docket?
Like, are there specific case management softwares that maybe you don't need
something like Lead Docket?
And if so, which are those that can, is there any other tool you recommend
besides Lead Docket?
If your firm is spending money to attract leads and cases, you want to ensure that
you are investing in some sort of a funnel to nurture those leads and that you have
a team, so an intake team that is empowered to manage those leads, that knows
exactly what questions to ask, right?
And that understands how to use a CRM.
I mentioned Lead Docket because I love Lead Docket.
So I sometimes have firms that are like, oh, well, I do this through my case
management software, whether it's like Smart Advocate or Clio, and they're
utilizing the actual case management software for intake.
Have you seen a case management software that can do what Lead Docket can do?
No.
My preference is always get Lead Docket, sync it with CallRail.
That's my preference.
Give me the reports, right?
The case management system is a case management system.
Yes.
I agree.
But I think it's like, sometimes I just think it's like a lot for a law firm.
Of course.
Like emotionally, like forget the everything else.
Like emotionally, it's like, wait, I have a case management software.
Now I got to teach my team to use this other software and I got to implement it
and I got to, you know, what is it called?
Integrate it with my case management software and I got to get them on board.
And now the team's bitching and like, I don't want to hear it.
And it's just like so many things that go into it.
So like, I'm not trying to be insensitive.
Of course.
I run a business.
I know what it's like to roll out a new tool.
Right.
Yeah.
But I think it's so, so important.
Okay.
So going back to fundamentals, you start with data.
You tailor the approach depending on the intake specialist's prior knowledge.
And then what?
And then we hit empathy.
Oh, I was waiting.
I was waiting.
I'm like, when is she going to bring up empathy?
Then we bring empathy in.
I would have lost all respect if you hadn't brought it up.
No.
So we start at the fundamentals and then we move on to empathy.
But I have a question about empathy.
So let's just start here.
Yes.
I think I know what you're going to say.
Can you teach someone to be empathetic?
Okay.
So this is an unpopular opinion.
You're going to say yes.
I believe so, but let me finish my thought.
Okay.
I believe that you can teach someone empathy or at least fake it to fake it or
identify opportunities to be empathetic.
The reason is because I think that often it's not that someone might not have
empathy.
They just may not have the tools to show it, to show it.
Correct.
It could stem from their upbringing.
Maybe they didn't have a good example of how to articulate or express empathy.
There was a meme that went around for years where it was like a friend who
would poke another person that was crying with a stick, like, are you okay?
Just to kind of give an example of a friend who doesn't know what to say that
happens.
But do you think it's like worth it at that point?
Because, so here's my thing, and like I use friendliness as like the other one,
right?
Are you friendly and are you empathetic?
And I think they're two separate things.
I think you can be very empathetic without being the friendliest.
I think that you do need to have, and I guess there's a third category.
It's like obviously positive attitude.
So like in terms of like culture and team and like being a good employee, right?
And then there's friendliness.
And I don't think you can teach someone to be friendly.
That's different.
I agree with you.
And I agree that you can teach someone that maybe doesn't come across as the
most empathetic to come across more empathetic.
But I guess my question is, is it worth it?
Because if I'm interviewing someone and I've said this before on the podcast,
like I would try to like, I don't know, be like, Oh, I have the worst headache.
Or like, I slept like shit last night just to see if they're like, Oh, I'm so
sorry.
Like, do you need to reschedule?
Like, do they show that empathy or are they like just ready to talk about
themselves?
Yeah.
Right.
Like that's something I would do because to me it's like if I can hit on
positive attitude, which I can tell if you have positive attitude in two seconds
in there, literally two, I will end an interview three minutes in if I don't
think you have positive attitude.
Are you friendly?
I think that can very quickly be: you're either friendly or you're not,
and I can tell when someone is faking friendliness. I think it's, like, very
easy to see that. Yeah. I think the empathy part is a little bit trickier because you
could, again, maybe not, maybe you are empathetic and you feel the empathy and you don't know
how to show it. But I just think that's a tougher thing to hire for. So what are your
thoughts? So I think that obviously, if we want to, in our screening, assess for empathy,
assess for their skills, right, that's important. But sometimes we have someone that killed
their interview. They seemed extremely, you know, they said they were empathetic, right?
But they didn't have to be empathetic towards you during that interview. That's why I headache.
So it's sometimes you're left in a position where you listen to a call and you realize
this team member is great. We thought they were super empathetic, but they just didn't
have the words to validate this person who is, you know, experienced a catastrophic injury.
And that person could have been extremely empathetic in that moment, but just did not
have the words to comfort that person and didn't know what to say. It happens. So I
think that it is worth it if that team member is a willing team member. We only train and
we only work with willing team members. If they're willing, then I think it's worth it.
It's hard to find someone that's going to be that's going to check all the boxes. And
if they surprise you, I do think it's worth investing in them. So long as you're willing,
if they're apathetic, on the other hand, I would be great. You would. I really think
I would be great at it. I'd be bored in like three minutes. But I think I'd be good because
here's the last component. Okay. Right. Okay. No, I don't want to do intake. No one asked me
to do intake. Here's the last component. Can they close? I know it's still a sales job.
And I just think it's such a unique type of sales because it does require that empathy.
And if we think of salespeople, like the first thing that comes to mind, typically,
when somebody says salesperson, it's like a car salesman. And I don't think that I would like
nothing against car sales men at all or women. I just don't think you automatically think like
empathy when you think of that person. Right. So I think law firms get really turned off when it's
like this is a sales team. And they're like, how do I reconcile the willingness, the friendliness,
the empathy, and then you got to be able to sign up the case. Right. So the way that we package
that is we use purpose. We actually try not to use the word sales. We'll use it with, you know,
clients sometimes, but we try to refrain from that with the actual intake team. And it's because
the reason why you mentioned a salesperson selling cars is because we think of someone
that doesn't have our best interests at heart. Right. Right. So when you asked the question
earlier about fundamentals, we also introduce a couple of core beliefs into the intake team.
And one of those is that they're an ambassador of the firm, that they help remove friction for
all clients to gain access to get legal representation and to remind themselves
that they have the most important job in the firm. When a prospect contacts the firm,
it is because they need help and they called the firm. So if you are following up,
if you are moving forward with the ask, whatever you want to call it, right, to sign up the case,
to make the sale, you are helping them get the help that they need. They needed that. Sometimes
they need you to overcome their objections in order for them to know that I'm making the right
decision. A prospect will often say, oh, you know, I don't want my boss to think that I'm
a terrible person. And I know I got hurt at work, but but they're also looking through waiting
for you to also tell them, no, that's all right. This is how the process works. Some people need
that extra validation. So we teach the intake teams to identify those moments, to reaffirm
prospects about why they contacted the firm to begin with. But we don't focus so much on the
close as much as you do what it takes to help facilitate the firm's next success story and to
ensure that you're getting that person help and you relate to them. I always actually give the
example of like my own mother. So my mom was a single mother. She was a widow, immigrant,
and she was hurt on the job when I was really young. And she never went to get help from an
attorney whatsoever because she felt like I'll bounce back. You know, everything will be fine.
That's a very immigrant mentality. And they don't want to miss work. So like all these
components come into play. But she never did. She ended up going on to have numerous surgeries. She
had a spinal fusion. I'm sorry. Just a couple years ago. And that is the perfect example of
someone who might be on the call with an intake specialist and say, you know what, I'm just
probably going to feel better. You know what? I forget about all this. That is the response. That
is when it is the responsibility of the intake specialist to remind them of their statute of
limitations, to remind them that their injuries can get worse. So when you think about it from
the lens of purpose and having that prospect's best interest at heart, it doesn't feel dirty
whatsoever. I love that. It feels like a responsibility. I love that because I think,
again, it's hard bridging that gap. But from like an agency standpoint, I'm like, how do I get across
to the clients that this is still? I know it's like sounds dirty to call it sales, whatever,
but it is like still at the end of the day. And I guess it leads me to my next question. Like,
what would you consider a good sign up rate? So if there are 100 wanted cases that come in in a
month, which I know that's like for a lot of people, that would be amazing. Right. But what
how many should they be signing? So I will say I'm going to give a lawyer answer. It depends.
But let's say they're all wanted cases. Are they MedMals?
Well, no, because MedMals, they're probably like one case in there. But let's just assume that it's
a personal injury firm with no threshold. So they'll take a soft tissue minimum policy case.
And that's why I use the word wanted because for MedMal, they could get 100 calls, but they really
only want one. Right. One wanted. Right. So I mean, wanted like it hits every they check every box.
They're like, I want to sign this case up. Yeah. It meets the firm's criteria. It could be
the firm could have a seven figure threshold. It could have, again, soft tissue. They'll take any.
Yeah. Right. Assuming they want the case, 100 cases come in at any period of time. Forget the
month. What would you say is considered a good sign up rate? If we want all 100 cases? Yes.
That's what they want. They're wanted cases. If we want them, they're truly wanted cases.
We should sign every single one up. But that's unrealistic in my opinion. So
if they meet our criteria, every single one of them, right, they actually are a wanted case,
which that's why I asked earlier, are any of them MedMals? Because the MedMal can be considered a
wanted case. It can sit in the wanted status for two months while they're getting medical records
and it will impact. But see, that wouldn't count because then it becomes rejected. Right. Right.
I mean, truly, what is the percentage? Because the numbers that I typically hear
fall in the 90 to 95%. Do you agree with that? If you're looking at a firm that,
let's say they have the data component done, right, and you're going and you're saying, okay,
there was 100 cases in the last X amount of months that you wanted, but you only signed 60.
Are you concerned or are you like, that's a great sign up rate?
No, we're looking at the rest. We're looking to find out why didn't we sign up those other cases
to look for the core issues. And you're going to have scenarios where you could have a percentage
of those that hired another attorney. Right. Okay. You know, it's interesting, most of the
leads that where they hired another attorney are from web chat and web form because of the
response time. So we're able to really hone in on that to see. And that's my next question with like
cadences and follow-ups, but I'll get to that. But I'm not going to let you move forward until
you give me a good number. What do you feel good about? Like you've worked with a firm for a year,
what should their wanted close rate be at for you to feel like this is doing great? Obviously,
it could change in like literally a second. I'm not going to discount that. And this needs,
I think if anybody's going to take anything away from this, maybe everything Yani says,
you don't agree with, which I mean, that's problematic, but
this is ongoing. Like it's not a set and forget it. You can't just train your team,
set it and forget it. There has to be quality control in place. Absolutely. But at what point
do you say this is good? I'm not so worried about it. If your wanted conversion rate is actually
90%. I love actually, I love why you said that because you know, that's my thing we talked about,
right? That's great. If it's actually 90%, that's great. I'm going to tell you every firm
is different. Again, I'm really going back to maybe this firm handles a type of personal injury
case that has like a longer lead management cycle, like a nursing home or a med mal. Those cases,
unfortunately, will hurt the conversion rate. So like a 75% for them could be pretty good.
But just a standard PI firm. A standard PI firm, let's say they're a volume firm. We want to be at
at least I would say 80% and up. Where are the rest going? They hired another attorney.
Most of them due to response time and the second is due to poor follow-up.
Okay, so let's talk about this. Because this is like another of my sticking points. Talk
to me about, let's start with response time. Somebody submits a chat or a web form or calls
a firm and for some reason the call is missed. How much time do they have to have a reasonable
chance at still signing the case? If they missed the call?
They missed the call or it just came in through the web form. How much time? How quickly do
they need to act? I'm being dead serious because you know and
I know. I know. I think that's hopeful that you could still get the case and you let it
go to voicemail. But I would say immediately. So, unfortunately, if you missed the call.
Okay. I know. If you missed the call, don't even get me started on that. You work with
some of my clients where we're having this exact issue. And it's like one thing that
we started doing. I don't know. Have you seen the emails?
Yes. I love them. Do you? The weekly recaps. Yes. So, what we've been doing for our clients
is giving them a monthly, not a monthly, a weekly recap of the prior week. How many missed
calls they had. How many Google reviews they got. And we're actually calling their law
firm and seeing how many rings it takes. Yes.
So I'll start and I want to like remember to come back to how many rings it should take.
But talking about responsiveness, somebody submits a web chat or a web form, how long
do they have to contact them? So, our rule is immediately. Immediately.
And can you set up automations? Automations for like an auto-reply or?
Yes. Yeah. We set them up for all of our clients.
Thank you. All of our clients. We immediately, the minute
that you submit an online form or a web chat, you are going into a high engagement funnel.
And what do you use for that, if anything? Lead Docket.
Thank you. This is not sponsored by Lead Docket.
They would swear we're like getting paid by Lead Docket. Look, Lead Docket, if you want
to pay me, let me know. I second that.
And we will, you know, take us to dinner or something.
Right, right. But immediately.
But you know why? It actually helps our clients. So, it's not about, it could be called, it
could be any company. I don't care as long as it helps the client.
Right. Right. Okay. So, automatically they're
getting what? Emails, texts? Emails, texts, whatever contact source or
contact information method that they've provided. And how quickly do they have to call them,
though? So, we say as soon as possible. So, within,
if that's 30 seconds, if that's within a minute, as soon as possible. So, we implement a, if
you see it and you are able, like you're not on the phone, you grab it and you call. Versus
grabbing it, assigning it to someone, and then maybe they have two more calls, outbound
calls that they need to make. And then, therefore, that person might go 30 minutes before being
called. Do not have an alphabet system to disperse leads because that's what will happen.
You must have a whoever is available next, whoever's off the phone next, needs to be
the person to contact, make an outbound call to contact this web form or this web chat
that came in. Now, how do you ensure that multiple people
aren't calling at the same time? So, with Lead Docket, it actually blocks it
out. If you are in Lead Docket and you've opened up an opportunity, it's impossible
for another person to open it up because they'll strike it out and they'll say,
Maria is calling Sari Beth in Alabama. Perfect. Okay. Now, how many rings should it
take? And I don't know if we have enough time to get into, like, the whole phone tree scenarios
and, like, what is, what provides the best user experience, right? So, first let's start
with how many rings until it's picked up? So, I'm honestly going to give a, if you
can ring, if you can pick up the phone in the second ring, pick up the phone on the
second ring, set up your systems, set up your team, make sure that you have an after hours
call center if you're not staffed up, right? Is there one that you like?
You know, I think it's an industry thing. It's hard, but there are a lot of great ones.
There are a lot of great ones we have. You don't want to name them?
So, right now, I think Intake Solutions of America is doing a really good job for some of
our mutual clients. So, they seem to be doing a good job at the moment. And
GoAnswer has done a good job for some of my clients in the past as well. And I know that
some are happy with SmithAI. Yeah, I've heard that too. I've also,
the one that I've recently been recommending is Legal Conversion Center.
I actually have a client who just got Legal Conversion Center.
LCC. Yes.
Yeah. But I'd love, I need to talk to all of them. I want to.
I don't have a lot of, I haven't worked with them before.
What I don't like is only giving the client one option because then if it goes poorly,
it's going to reflect back on me. And I've always said like, look.
Yes.
It's not that necessarily I want to put all the blame on like a call center. I just think that's
a really, really fucking hard job. Like, to run a call center.
It is. Yeah.
It's just, it's hard. And like, I just think that you really are looking for like,
who's the best of the worst and not because of anything necessarily that's their fault.
I just think it's inherently like impossible. Like, no one's going to do Intake better than
setting it up correctly in-house. Period. And don't get me wrong. If you call LawRank,
half the time it's going to go to an answering service, right? Half the time it'll ring to
someone, but half the time it won't. But what we do is not as time sensitive as what you guys do
or what law firms do, right? Not you. Okay. So two rings is what I say as well.
The other thing is like, we just had this with a mutual client where it's ringing to one person.
Then if that person doesn't pick up, it goes to the rest of the team or to another person,
I can't remember. So now it's creating all these rings, right? As opposed to
the phone ringing at multiple desks at once. Like, what are your feelings on that? And what
kind of phone trees should law firms set up? And before we even go into that really quickly,
how do you feel, before I forget, about phone rings? Press one if you're an existing client,
press two if you're a new client. Okay. So this is going to be an
unpopular opinion too. I love unpopular opinion. I know how SEO agencies feel about phone trees,
but so this is what my experience and what my perspective is about the call routing system
and phone trees. So if you have a call tracking number set up, just route your LSA calls to the
intake team pod. It's going to skip- I agree with that.
Right? Skips the receptionist. It skips the having to go through a phone tree.
I agree with that. So we always opt for that,
right? Yes.
Because you're going to save rings and they're going to get to the team as quickly as possible.
And if that team does not answer within a couple rings, then we can move into our overflow
structure, whether that's a call center, right? Or maybe a paralegal that's a backup, which we
actually don't recommend either because they're busy and they may not follow up on that lead.
So we recommend pointing them directly to the departments when necessary. A phone tree actually
helps with that. But I think the reason that a lot of people hate phone trees is because it sounds
so mechanical, right? So we love to help our clients set up a highly personalized phone tree
if they opt in for one where the managing partner's voice is, you know, he's using his own
voice where he's welcoming them to the firm. If they're calling about an existing case, press one,
or a new case, press two. And even when they're holding, they're listening to maybe audio of
a commercial that they've done that has like a client testimonial or their value propositions,
because unfortunately, sometimes you do have to be placed on hold. But why not make it a hero's
journey while they're waiting? I absolutely love that. So I think that if we make the tour,
you know, a little bit more personal, it becomes less of a negative experience. So
I think phone trees are great when you make it like the most elevated experience. I love that.
Now, how do you feel about the firms that have a receptionist that then routes the call, right?
And what I run into is that the receptionist will pick up the phone. Now, they're not an
intake specialist. They're literally just the phone router, right? And they get on the phone
with someone that is just dying to tell them about their case. And they just start regurgitating. And
then the receptionist either lets them talk or interrupts them. And I don't think there's like,
even like a good way, period, to handle this. Because if you let them talk, now they're going
to have to repeat their story. If you interrupt them, they're going to find that you're rude.
So obviously, clearly, you can tell how I feel about it. But how do you feel about it?
So we teach our intake teams call control. And we have very specific training for receptionists.
What we do is when a what we advise is that when a receptionist is taking a call, and asking,
is this about a new case, or an existing case, if they say new case, the first thing that they say,
and do is set an expectation. Thank you, Maria, for calling us about your new case,
I'm going to transfer you to an intake specialist is going to, you know, ask you the questions about
this case, and they're going to be able to help you with that. What I'm going to do is just take
your name, and number, just in case we get disconnected before I transfer you over, you get
it in, in terms of what the expectation is, before they have the ability to share, you're not always
going to have that opportunity because someone may steamroll, right and just move on to the call.
What about just and I'm thinking out loud, but right when they pick
up the phone, saying something like it, I don't know about a new or existing case.
While you calling, could you please tell me if you're calling about a new or existing case so I
can best know how to transfer your call? Like saying it in the introduction, somehow like
getting it in there. So hopefully something clicks in that person's head of like, I'm going to be
transferred. Yeah, right. Yeah. So that's interesting because a phone tree does that
in a lot of ways, right? Except for you have, you know, a real person asking that question,
right? But you have a little bit more control with the phone tree because they know what to expect.
So I think that the goal is to set an expectation and you can, you know, modify the script so that
you can, you know, ensure that they know that I'm not the person that's going to be taking this
information. And the goal is to be able to set that expectation before you even collect their
phone number. What do you think is better? Phone rings to all the intake specialists,
none are available. Should it go to the paralegals who are in the middle of doing something and
they're distracted? And it's so hard in my opinion. And I hear this in intake where they're
still working on whatever it is they're working on, even during the intake, because it's so,
and I, I'm not, I can relate. I think when you're in the middle of doing something and then like,
you know, my kid walks in and they want something and I'm just like,
I'm not listening to you right now. And I literally have to turn to my kid and be like,
hey, I want to give you the attention that like this deserves. I'm in the middle of something.
I can't do that for you right now, but I do want to give you that attention, right?
Obviously they can't, a paralegal can't do that on the, on the phone with,
so is it better for it to go to a paralegal that might not be able to turn that switch
off and then the new switch on or for it to just go to after hours?
I actually have a very strong opinion about this.
I always want to be diplomatic though.
No, this is not, this is not the podcast to be diplomatic. People do not listen to this,
that get offended easily because they would just like live offended.
So there's something to be said about transferring a call that means that it could be more work
for someone, right? And then giving them the power to, to make the decision of whether this is
a new work order, essentially, if we're putting it in those terms, right?
So if a paralegal is busy and they have a responsibility, it's really not fair for them
either to have to stop what they're doing and then process an intake. And then it'd be expected to
follow up on that intake. They're most likely going to miss best practices to maybe enter
it into the system, which we see all of the time. They're just trying to get it off. They're trying
to get back to what they were doing. They may not, they may not enter it into the system.
So it doesn't go into this followup funnel or in the event that they feel that they are overworked
at that moment, they may set a higher criteria than the firm has in order to reject the case
because they don't want to open another file.
Thank you. I was hoping you would hit on this.
Yeah.
Because there's reason why people that are going to work on the case,
especially if they're not vested in it, like, obviously, if you're a partner or the owner,
shouldn't have to sign up the case because now it's like, oh, here's another case where I'm
going to have more work. Right. And that's the reality of things. Right. It's like,
I don't want to get into it, but I feel I feel very strongly about it, too.
It's true. And that's why I have a very strong opinion about it.
One of our goals, our primary goal is we are trying to decentralize lawyers from intake.
Lawyers feel like I'm going to be like the one that signs up all the cases like I'm Harvey
Specter, like I need to be the one that gets on the phone. And in one way, I could see that.
Right. Like, of course, talking to a lawyer is going to be more beneficial in some ways,
like I could see why that would be super helpful. Right. But on the other end, I'm like.
But wouldn't your time be best spent doing something else like prepping for trial or
managing the business? And I think that there is this belief in our space, especially when
law firms are like in their first few years that the lawyer has to be the one to do the intake and
be involved in the intake. And what is an intake specialist going to do? Some lawyers will be like,
wait, they're going to sign up the case. They're going to determine if this is a case or not.
And how do you feel about that? And then I guess the follow up question would be, what about is
there a time that is appropriate to say, let me transfer you to our to one of our lawyers?
Yeah, absolutely. I think it all boils down to availability. So if you are a lawyer and you just
are available to screen cases that you want and do not want all day long and you're able to also
keep up with other things, which means that we're not letting people off the phone, right, to take a
message to have a lawyer call them back. Oh, yes. That's where we see the bottleneck. I literally
hear this, like even when we're like monitoring LSA calls, right. And we're like listening and
notating. And I will tell the team, like, OK, well, how many of these ended up in signups? And
they'll be like, well, there's no way for me to know because it's always like I'll have a lawyer
call you back. And I'm like, what? I'm like, put me on an email thread. Like, I'm just like that
should not be happening. Right. It's like if they're not available, then just sign up the case
if you need to reject later, reject it. How is the intake team not trained on what cases sign up and
which cases not sign up? Right. But getting through to the lawyers sometimes, I don't know if you
struggle with this, especially I would argue with like the newer or more boutique firms that I
personally think there's like some limiting beliefs around it, like nobody else is going to
be able to do this as well as me. I'm needed for this. And I'm like, well, I mean, how does Morgan
and Morgan do it? Like, I think that it comes from lawyers feeling like they have to be involved in
their intake process. I think it's coming from a place of wanting what's best for their clients.
They truly believe that I'm the only person that can, you know, qualify this case and really ask
the questions that are necessary. My intake team isn't trained on that. I don't have time to train
them on this. And it just becomes this cycle. Right. I don't have time to train them on this.
I need help. I'm probably losing cases because I'm having to call them back. And then they've
hired another attorney. And until I can spend the time to train them, I'm just going to have
to continue to take these intakes myself. And it's just a vicious cycle. There's no freedom.
And I think the other component to add, a lot of lawyers, at least the lawyers that we work with,
are trial lawyers. Right. So they are used to getting these very warm leads. Right. But the
moment they start doing any sort of marketing, I'm like, the marketing cold lead isn't going to
wait for your callback. They are just not going to wait for your callback. So I think it's also
and do you guys factor that when you're auditing intake? Do you factor in that not all leads are
created equal? Right. And like, how is that addressed? I want to just go back and finish
answering the other question for lawyers listening to this and wondering, can there ever be a future
where I'm not stuck doing an intake call on a Saturday instead of spending time with my family?
Yes, you have to invest in either a resource to train your intake team. They can learn how to
approach a call with the empathy that's necessary, how to identify a viable case, a valuable case
for all of your case types. And they're going to do a better job at following up with that lead
because they'll be solely responsible for doing that. So it can happen. I just want any lawyer
to listen to this to know that there's that freedom is possible for their firm. And with that
comes growth because you have someone that is available to actually nurture those leads that
you've invested to attract into your firm. The goal is to try to create a standard and a process
for everything. If there is a trend where you let's say that, you know, if it's not clear,
if your intake team doesn't have a clear criteria of when to sign up a car accident case,
take the time to document that, right, or work with someone that can help you do that.
And with a car accident case, I am under the strong belief that an intake team should be
able to identify that case and sign them up without bringing in a lawyer. When it comes to
another type of case where maybe there are nuances like a premises liability, what I like to do,
and someone internally, right, that's not working with us can do this as well, is take the time
to go through a premises liability case so that you interview the attorney and you bring the
attorney. These are the leads that you signed up. These are the leads that you rejected. Why did
you reject this lead? Also, if an attorney is responding in response to a lead that was sent
with additional questions, just add those questions to the intake questionnaire. That's
important information that can be asked during the intake process. And the goal is to build out
your intake process so much that the attorney can just make a decision should they have to be
involved. If they have to be involved, that indicates that perhaps there is an opportunity
to document the criteria for this so that the intake team can handle this case. So what we do
is, and sometimes it takes one, two, or three sessions where we sit down with the attorney
and we truly understand all of the information that they need. And now that you have this
information, what do you consider a weak case? What do you consider a really strong case? And
why? So we just dig and dig and we probe and we probe and then we document the criteria.
We're the intake team so that they have a roadmap of,
this is a clear signup, we might reject it later,
but this is one that they will feel really good about
if you don't let pass, right?
And this is what they consider a weak case.
It's okay for you to bring in an attorney
just in case there's maybe some nuances
that they'll be able to discover,
but you wanna get as close as possible.
And then of course you have your med mals.
If I were a law firm, and you know you're gonna get
X amount, if you're lucky, of seven, eight-figure cases,
if it's a catastrophic truck accident
and you know the trucking company,
you know that there's gonna already be
a minimum policy of millions,
is it like, hey, we have a really fucking hot lead?
I need an attorney that can ideally also sign up cases.
So I think that that's another,
I don't want anyone to get mad at me,
I know all of you think you're the best at signing up cases,
but I do think there are lawyers
that are better at it than others.
I've even heard some that I think the lawyers
can be kind of rude and condescending,
and I'm like struggling because-
They're busy, which is why you should have an intake team.
Okay, yes, but now let's,
and typically I hear this when people
don't actually have a case, right, believe it or not,
is when I hear more, and I'm like,
oh, that was the chance for a review,
explain to them why they don't have a case,
be friendly, get me that review.
But that's a whole conversation for another day.
Is there a point where it's like,
if this magic criteria hits, we involve a lawyer?
Or do you think, no, the intake team
should be the best at closing it,
they should have examples of results
of cases that have been gone to trial.
Should they explain, if there's a trial firm,
should they explain the difference between a settlement firm
or a pre-litigation firm and a firm
that actually goes to trial?
Because this is something I hear a lot from lawyers, right?
We actually go to trial and they're so proud of it.
And I'm like, how proud you are,
I wanna hear your intake be that proud.
And explain to the average consumer,
they don't understand the difference
between you and a big advertiser
that you claim doesn't go to trial.
Because I'm not trying to put down big advertisers either.
I think that's a super hard job, right?
I'm all about marketing, so kudos to them.
But what I hear from the trial lawyer is,
all these people ranking, or not all,
but A, B, C, and D, and this big,
they don't go to trial.
Okay, is that passion coming through?
And I know where I'm like, I'm always like-
No, I'm keeping up with the questions.
Well, it's all kind of flows, right?
So let's just go back.
Is there a point when the lawyer has to be brought back in?
So we establish what we call an escalation policy.
So all prospects, all potential injured people
should be given the same level of service,
but there are some that we escalate,
which means that that intake specialist
is going to actually cover their same call path
as they would with any other viable claim,
which actually includes things like
establishing the value propositions
of the fact that perhaps we are trial attorneys, right?
And that we have this experience,
or maybe we have attorneys
that have practiced on the defense side
and they understand, right?
And then they have that intel knowledge.
All of that has already been sprinkled
throughout the call, right?
If the intake specialist is applying that.
Which I would argue is sales.
Yes.
So if there is a case where there is like
an overnight hospitalization involved, right?
Or a TBI injury, not only,
so the conversion or the ask is different.
It's when can we come to you?
When can we come to the hospital?
So they're still expected to have that same level of gusto
when it comes to making the close,
but the close means when's the appointment,
when's visiting schedule.
They're still explaining how everything works,
but they're giving them VIP service.
So they're still expected to follow that.
They're not going to stop what they're doing,
look for an attorney, maybe they're busy
and then have to call that person back.
They're just sending it off.
It's in motion, there's nothing to think about,
put it on the attorney's calendar and get it scheduled.
And the attorneys all had that expectation.
They would be more than happy on a weekend.
Right.
Oh, I'm sure.
To attend that, just put it on their schedule.
So we have an escalation policy
that's about the level of urgency
of when you can just sign it up
versus sign it up, schedule an appointment
and get the ball rolling immediately.
Got it.
And then now my second question,
you've kind of already answered it is,
do you have a very specific
or do you recommend that law firms
have very specific processes per type of case
and like results and, you know,
whether it's settlements or verdicts or expertise
and really tailoring it to the type of case
or type of, you know, accident or injury that occurred?
Absolutely.
So your intake process for every case type
should be very tailored to that case type
or that sub liability.
It should be very tailored to that.
It should include very granular questions
while having control of the call
but just being able to know when to pivot.
Your intake team can learn these things.
It's very possible.
It just takes time to map this stuff out.
When it comes to being able to share results,
a lot of our clients have intake teams
with team members that had pre-lit experience
within their firm.
So they have that advantage,
but we've also worked with intake teams
where maybe they were a little newer to the industry.
So they need more resources like, you know,
prior settlements, but we love that.
We love when our firms can share maybe a recent verdict
or a settlement with their team
and give them an archive or a collection, right,
of stories that they can share
because they may not have a point of reference
where they can relate to it personally,
but they're able to share what the experience is like
for someone that has gone through it as a client
and how they came out on the other side
to the best of their ability, right,
to indemnify them at least,
but they're able to come to them
with a point of reference that humanizes someone else
that's been through this.
I know what you've been through.
We actually had someone else that recently went through this
and this is how we were able to take care of them.
We always ask our clients
or any firms that's listening to this,
if you do share a success story with your team,
do not send a Lawyer's Weekly article.
Sit down with your team and practice storytelling.
Tell them how this case played out,
how it impacted their family.
Humanize it for them.
If they see that passion in you,
it's just gonna feel that purpose that we spoke about
at the beginning of this.
So you don't have to do it every week,
but just take the time,
even if it's once a quarter,
to just share one or two stories
and be proud when you're sharing that
and it's really going to give them
the purpose that they need to truly believe
that they have the most important job in the firm.
So you know what's super interesting
as I'm hearing you talk?
I see so many correlations in the way
that trial lawyers talk about speaking to a jury
in the way that their intake team
should be speaking to these potential clients.
Do you see that?
Of course, storytelling is storytelling.
Isn't that crazy though?
Because you would think that they would be
the best at intake.
Maybe we just need to make this like correlation for them.
I swear, just one last thing,
and then I will let you go
because that you said it
and I'm like, we need to talk about this.
How do you teach an intake specialist
to have and retain control of the call?
And the reason that I asked this is because I think that
their ability to remain in control of the conversation
kind of taps into authority
and that authority of like how they perceive the firm
and how they perceive them to be experts.
And I think oftentimes lawyers don't understand
or don't want to acknowledge that
because this is the first point of contact
potentially typically it is, right?
They are the firm in that moment.
So if they are not friendly and empathetic
and come across as an expert and passionate and with purpose,
that means that their firm
and everything that the lawyer stands for
isn't coming across.
Yeah, absolutely.
They really are the first impression
and they're going to be measured
based on what the firm
or what the potential client thought about the firm
versus what they actually experienced, right?
When they're on that call with the intake specialist.
So how an intake specialist
can maintain control of the call
is to guide the caller or the prospect, right?
Whatever format throughout the entire call
that's setting an agenda, having empathy,
but, and this is something I'll share.
I hope everyone uses this
but you can tailor it to your firm.
So we teach intake specialists
something called the Imago Dialogue.
I could be mispronouncing that second
or messing up that second part,
but it's the Imago Dialogue.
And it teaches the intake specialist
to be able to validate, to empathize,
but segue into a solution.
Otherwise it just becomes one big therapeutic session
of, oh my God, I can't believe that happened to you.
That sounds terrible.
I know, let me tell you more.
And it just continues and it's in a one-hour call.
So what we teach them is to empathize,
you can validate,
and then you have,
we have a list of one-liners that they can use
that segues them into the solution.
So for instance, right?
I could validate you and empathize with you
and I'm so glad.
Hold on.
When you say validate and empathize,
do you teach them to, like,
say what they said? What do you call it when you do that?
To mirror. Mirror.
It's part of the Imago dialogue.
Oh, okay, okay.
So that's what I'm going into.
Yes.
It's like very Chris Voss.
If you've ever read Never Split the Difference,
it's like you mirror.
Mirror back to them.
Right.
Yes, you validate.
Yes.
You know who else teaches this?
It's actually a lawyer that teaches this
that's not in our space.
It's like Shawn Callaway.
Okay.
And I believe he's blind, he's a lawyer,
and he teaches something very similar.
He says, I've never taken this course because I'm so busy,
but I've wanted to because he literally talks
about mirroring and validating.
Yes, and it's so important because often
when someone is repeating themselves over and over again,
when we think about our own personal relationships
where you might have had a disagreement
and we're just kind of going in circles,
it's because we think that the other person
isn't listening to us.
Right.
Right?
We don't think that they understand.
You mirror, how do you validate?
What's the difference between-
Mirroring and validating.
Yeah, why don't you explain what the difference is?
Yeah, so if I am showing empathy, right?
I am acknowledging that I can imagine how you feel.
I can imagine that you feel frustrated
dealing with this unexpected event in your life.
Yeah, it sounds like this was very frustrating.
Yes, so that is more of an understanding, right?
We can put ourselves in their shoes.
Whereas validating doesn't necessarily mean
that you agree with them, right?
It just means that it makes sense.
And this will be a joke.
It makes sense that you might be a little frustrated
because you've left three voicemails to your paralegal
and you haven't received a call back.
It makes sense that you feel that way.
I'm not agreeing with them.
I'm not saying what you're saying is right,
but it stops that call from becoming an unhinged call
of projecting and a very upset caller on the other line.
So by just letting them know that based on what you believe,
it makes sense that you would feel this way.
That person feels heard,
and it allows you to validate someone
that possibly is wrong, right?
But we don't have to disagree with them,
but we're able to maintain control of the call
and then segue the solution.
So it makes sense that you feel X, Y, and Z,
and I'm glad that you called me for help.
And what I wanna do next is you just completely segue
into the solution to get control of the call.
But if anyone wants to look it up,
it's like a modified imago dialogue that they can apply.
But I just have a question.
What is the difference?
Because to me, validating mirroring
almost sounds like you're combining it.
By just saying it makes sense, that's the validating part,
but then the mirroring part is saying back to them
whatever it is that they're frustrated about.
So it's like a better mirroring, in my opinion.
Yeah, yeah.
So when you're validating-
Rudy's texting that you're presenting in five minutes.
I thought it was at-
I thought it was running late.
I thought it was 2.45.
Can you ask her?
Say, I get you downstairs.
No, she's just trying to call-
So we had a little bit of a scare
where we were told that I spoke in five minutes,
but it was really 20, so we were fine.
We kinda remember where we left off, but we kinda don't.
So this is not gonna be perfect,
but I think we left off on having very specific sales.
I know you don't like that.
You don't call it sales, but very specific.
What would you call it?
Talking points?
Yes, talking points.
Talking points and how to kinda tie all that into,
what was it that you said?
Mirroring and validating.
Validating, empathizing.
Yeah.
Can you just kinda maybe just tie it all in for us
in terms of controlling the call?
Yeah, absolutely.
So often when a potential caller is calling a firm,
it is very easy for that call to just derail.
And often we'll see an intake specialist
who needs call control training
be on the phone for up to an hour.
I am gonna be honest, that has happened to me.
10 years ago in a firm, I'd feel terrible for the caller
and I'd stay on the phone for an hour,
but that's not helpful.
And we're also not, as an intake specialist,
you're not placing yourself in a place of authority.
Yes.
I always think of the doctor.
When you go to the doctor's office,
do they just let you ramble and talk about what you Googled
and what you're gonna try and what you think you have?
Or are they like, hold on.
They ask you a bunch of questions.
They're like, this is what we're gonna do to figure it out
and then we'll come up with a game plan.
Exactly. Right?
Exactly.
So they set the agenda.
Yep.
They set the agenda.
I love that I'm gonna call it out going forward.
Yes.
This is what we're gonna do first.
And then we're gonna do that.
Yep.
And that will lead you to this.
So setting the agenda is crucial.
And when emotions creep up into that call
and start to derail the call,
that is where you can use tools like empathizing with them.
So I can imagine that you feel frustrated right now
with X, Y, and Z.
It makes sense that you're angry because X, Y, and Z.
When someone is telling their story
and they tend to be going through a loop,
mirroring is very helpful
because you're able to repeat back to them
what they said in a very clear and concise way
and ask them. And it feels hard.
Yeah.
Did I get that?
Is there anything that I'm missing?
Yeah.
That way they understand that you heard them,
that you understand what they're saying,
and then you segue into the solution.
Often when people are repeating themselves,
it's because they feel like you're missing something.
So that's very helpful in that case.
Do you train them to say stuff like, it sounds like?
I guess in a way that is part of validating them, right?
Because we're saying to them,
it makes sense that you feel this way, right?
From what I understand,
you'll experience X, Y, and Z and X, Y, and Z.
Did I get that?
Is that correct?
Yeah.
It gives them control to be able to say, yes,
that's correct.
You got everything.
Thank you.
They feel validated.
And even if there may be,
maybe if it's not warranted,
just validating them helps to end and land the plane,
especially if the emotional caller is maybe upset
over their case getting rejected, which is very common.
We're doing this a little bit backwards,
but I first wanted everyone to hear
how much knowledge you have.
But now I think we should back it up with like,
how do you know all this?
What is your background?
So can you quickly just tell us,
how did you learn about intake?
And what have you been doing for the past?
What is your experience basically?
I know you just started Legal Intake Pros.
Legal Intake Pros.
I just think of you.
I don't even think of the business.
And I was torn.
I'm not gonna lie about having you on
because you're like a secret weapon
that I use for my clients.
But I just think it's like such valuable information.
So give us a little bit of your background.
Yeah, so my entire career, just to recap,
has been focused on marketing and advertising,
specifically multicultural marketing and advertising
in the Latino community.
And that kind of segues somehow into the insurance industry.
So I was an insurance agent for many years,
writing car insurance policies, workers' comp policies,
commercial policies.
Yeah, and I oversaw a sales team.
That is where I got my sales experience.
Got it, okay.
That is where I really had an understanding
of property and casualty and insurance.
And interesting enough,
that led me into the personal injury space.
And I was working as an intake director
and a marketing director for a high volume firm
that practiced primarily workers' compensation
and personal injury cases.
And it was a fast growing firm.
I had a lot of pressure from all of the partners
to increase the number of signups.
That's why I mentioned at the beginning,
I was that person calling my SEO company
saying we need more leads.
But what I realized is that no matter how much
we were adding to that marketing spend,
it wasn't translating to sign cases.
And I realized we should probably hold up a mirror
to ourselves and look at what's happening to those calls,
to those leads, once they come into the firm.
It was a very attorney centric intake system.
So I then launched Lead Docket at that point
and we transitioned over to Filevine.
We tripled the size of the intake team
in the years following,
but I stopped focusing on our marketing reports
and I started to really like zoom in on our lost
and rejected leads.
I love that.
Yeah, and that's really what birthed
my passion for intake optimization.
And then I went on to just help other firms
across the country optimize their intake systems
and trying a couple of things
that I didn't have a chance to implement at the time.
And it's been truly a journey of just trial and error.
So that's kind of what led me to launch Legal Intake Pros
about nine months ago.
Now I have another question.
I can't help myself,
but like one of the problems that I see with intake
is that sometimes the team doesn't expand.
So it's like, let me throw more marketing dollars,
which then increases the call volume,
but it doesn't translate to more cases
because now the intake is inundated with calls.
And I just think even emotionally,
like just from like a human standpoint,
after X amount of phone calls in a day,
and knowing that calls are
going to after hours or whatever, right?
Calls are being missed.
Like, I just think that's not the right mindset
to be handling these intakes, right?
Do you see that as a problem too,
like understaffed intake teams?
Yes, but I do think that the way that we measure
when we need to expand the team
should come after optimizing.
So- I love that.
That makes perfect sense.
Remove all, find a way to automate,
find a way to remove all the manual labor
where you can, right?
Remove the friction internally,
remove the friction for the potential clients.
And then let's reassess
if this is more so an operational issue
in terms of our processes,
or if we need to expand our team.
If we've optimized the intake team and our intake processes,
and we are at the point now
where our response time is suffering,
that's a really good sign.
Let's scale up, let's hire someone else on the team.
But if we're choosing to keep the team at that size,
then it's gonna cost cases, obviously.
Going back to your experience,
after working at that firm,
you then worked at a digital marketing agency
offering these services, right?
Before going off on your own,
how long did you do that for?
Did that for about two years.
Wow, okay.
Yeah, about two years there.
And it was so much fun because when you're in-house,
when you're inside of the law firm
and you're able to accomplish this there,
it's really a challenge to see,
can I do this for other firms?
So when I was able to experiment
and help these other firms across the country
and saw them achieve this transformation,
it was like, I knew it was intake.
I knew it was intake.
It wasn't just there.
So I'm not crazy.
You're not crazy, she's right.
For me, so we had an issue recently
where a client sent me an upset email
and he was like,
I was getting 28 cases and I got 17 this month.
What went wrong?
And like, of course I just go to data, right?
And I go and I look at results.
Has anything changed in results?
Then I went and I looked at call volume.
Call volume was up.
So I called his cell phone.
I thought I was calling his cell phone,
but I had just upgraded cell phones
and it actually went to the firm.
And it took seven rings for the firm to pick up.
I called him back.
I told him what happened.
He fixed it.
The next month they got 34 cases.
Wow.
So I know, but it's just,
for me, it's hard to get everyone on board
with this, you know, belief, right?
Like everybody just talks about like,
I want more, I want to generate more calls.
And I'm like, well, are you maximized?
And it's weird because it's not like I offer,
like people think I'm like an expert.
I'm like, I'm not an expert.
Like, they're like, well, will you help me?
I'm like, you don't want me to help you.
Like, I know it more in theory than like intuitively
just from like having a sales background, right?
Then like in practice, right?
Which is why it's so neat to have you
and kind of hear you say all these things that I'm like,
okay, that makes sense.
Or like, I hadn't thought of that, you know,
like it's, this has been super helpful even for me.
Well, I've enjoyed this.
And just to your point, I know sales is sales.
I don't like to use sales,
but what you know and what's familiar to you,
what you know for sure,
of course it's going to make sense in the legal industry.
Right.
Any industry, any business that is advertising
for leads needs a funnel.
Right.
Right, it needs to nurture that funnel.
I do agree that it's a very particular type of sales
because of the empathy component.
Absolutely.
So again, that's where I kind of struggle
with like the terminology
because sales in a industry like this sounds dirty.
It does, right?
But when you talk about like the purpose behind it,
then that really kind of shifts.
And then just measuring numbers,
like you don't have to refer to it as a sales team,
but if you're looking at this numbers,
you have quality control in place,
you're doing a lot of things that in my opinion,
I would consider sales.
Like maybe you don't give it that title,
but you're doing things that I think are very similar,
even just a funnel, right?
Using Lead Docket the way I would use a CRM tool, right?
Having quality control in place, having a script.
And I agree with you.
I love scripts,
as long as you're not reading the script verbatim.
It's like you need to memorize the key concepts
of like the key talking points of the script.
And then you have to say them
in a way that sounds conversational
and that like makes sense to that point in time.
It's not like out of context, right?
And I think that's, in my opinion, the toughest part
is like saying use the script,
but don't read the script, right?
I think that's tough.
It's important for them to learn the opportunity,
how to identify the opportunities.
Do you role play?
We do role play.
Okay, cool.
We role play.
Sales, again, I'm telling you, I know, I know.
So Maria is right.
It is sales, client acquisition, as I like to call it.
I like that.
We can, I can get behind that.
Client acquisition, but you're right.
It's all the same, but because it's, but different.
It's all the same, but different
because there needs to be tons of empathy.
And it's, in my opinion, it's higher end sales.
And anytime that it's high end, it's very specialized.
And there's a lot of knowledge
that the person has to have, you know?
Absolutely.
So I think that's like the key component.
It's not just sales, it's high end sales.
And when you put it that way,
it almost changes it a little bit.
Like, I'm gonna start saying it that way.
Absolutely.
And it is absolutely possible for someone
besides the attorney to be really good at that
and to follow up.
Even better, I think.
Even better.
Well, thank you so much.
I really appreciate this.
Yeah, thank you.
I really enjoyed this.
How can people get a hold of you?
If you're not my client, please don't call her.
You guys can reach me at LegalIntakePros.com
and Legal Intake Pros on all social media as well.
Perfect.
Thank you, Yani, I appreciate it.
Thanks, Maria.
Thank you to Yani Smith
for everything she shared with us today.
If you found this story valuable,
please share it with someone you want to see succeed.
Subscribe so you never miss an episode.
Leave a five-star review.
It goes a long way to help others discover the show.